anticiper liberté ce mot Amadou
Coulibaly le prononce quasiment dans
toutes ses phrases quand il parle de la
situation de son pays natal le Mali le
Guyancourtois est soulagé depuis
l'intervention de l'armée française le
10 janvier dernier on est dans un
costume de des gens qui n'ont plus peur
on a plus peur des islamistes là qui
nous interdisaient de fumer des boire
notre bière et de
s'exprimer concrètement comme ça se doit
notre fierté c'est que c'est la France
qui puisse nous libérer là en ce moment
on est fier de la France
lors de son dernier séjour à Bamako
pendant les fêtes de fin d'année le 56
mois également porte-parole d'un
collectif de son papier de Versailles a
pu voir l'entraînement de l'armée
malienne par les forces spéciales
françaises et l'atmosphère dans les rues
étaient particuliers c'était un peu
étendu quand même parce que les gens
étaient un peu inquiets en se disant que
ce sont les pires de fêtes où ces
islamistes peuvent taper donc tout le
monde était sur le qui-vive bon on a
tendance que soit puissent les
dispositions de sécurité
Amadou Coulibaly prend des nouvelles
quotidiennement de ces deux enfants
habitant à Bamako roqya et Gaoussou
avant peut-être de les faire rapatrier
en France